[Musique]
merci Olivier Bitz d'être avec nous
pendant cette première demi-heure malgré
une nuit longue et agitée on va en
parler vous êtes élu de l'ordre membr du
groupe RDPS ce sont les sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle et vous êtes
donc membres de cette commission mixte
paritaire est-ce que vous attendiez un
tel scénario nous savions que les
discussions allaient se se dérouler dans
le cadre de CNP donc il y a rien
d'anormal à ce que la commission mixte
paritaire qui a précisément pour objet
de trouver un accord entre députés et
sénateurs que cette commission bah donne
lieu effectivement un certain nombre de
débats et d'échanges mais là dès 17h
elle a été suspendu pendant de longues
heures elle a repris à 21h elle est
resuspendue vous reprenez ce matin à
10h30 vous aviez vraiment vu venir cela
ben ce que nous avions pas vu venir
c'était le vote à l'Assemblée nationale
la semaine dernière où une coalition
entre laanups l'R et Len ont finalement
abouti au rejet du texte avant même le
débat c'est même pas le rejet du texte
c'est le rejet du débat donc alors que
l'Assemblée nationale aurait dû avoir 15
jours pour débattre de ce sujet
important l'Assemblée nationale a décidé
de ne pas en débattre ce qui fait qu'il
y a eu une accélération du calendrier et
nous sommes aujourd'hui maintenant
contraints effectivement de faire plus
vite que ce qui était prévu au départ
mais pour moi il n'y a rien d'anormal
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter ce
qui s'est passé hier à 17h vous vous
réunissez début de cette CMP et lap la
suspension de séance a été quasi
immédiate pourquoi ben tout simplement
parce qu'il y avait encore des points à
discuter entre ceux qui avaient envie
d'avancer ensemble parce qu'il faut bien
voir que dans le cas de la CMP il y a
ceux qui veulent d'un accord et il y a
ceux je pense au rassemblement national
comme la nuups il y a ceux qui ne
veulent pas d'accord donc ceux qui
veulent un accord bah ont exprimé la
nécessité de poursuivre leurs échanges
mais pourquoi d 17h qui a demandé
d'abord la suspension de séance et pour
quel motif ben je je pense que ça venait
des des deux partis à la fois de la
majorité présidentielle et et des l'IR à
partir du moment où on sent qu'il n'est
pas
possible au moment où on demande la la
la levée de la la séance d'avancer et
ben dans ce cas-là effectivement ben on
prend un petit peu de temps pour
discuter essayer de se mettre d'accord
ça veut dire parce qu' on a quand même
vu qu'il y a eu 4 jours de de tractation
avant des réunions à Matignon avec les
LR avec les centristes ça veut dire que
tout n'était pas ficelé hier à 17h mais
jusqu'au moment du vote définitif du
texte rien n'est ficelé et tout doit
faire l'objet de discussion et et
d'accord et c'est c'est ser réfèire
insulte à ce qui'est une CMP si tout
était bouclé au moment d'arriver à la à
la Commission je comprends pas parce que
cela même qui nous reproche que tout ne
soit pas bouclé au moment d'arriver en
commission cela même là nous reproche
d'avoir commencé les travaux avant la
CMP donc un moment donné il faudrait
savoir quelle était l'ambiance puis
qu'après vous avez repris vos travaux à
21h jusqu'à minut 30 quelle a été
l'ambiance ben l'ambiance elle était
plutôt constructive j'ai envie de dire
entre d'une part la majorité
présidentielle et et d'autre part les
représentants LR à l'Assemblée au Sénat
mais on a aussi vu effectivement une
coalition entre s et RN pour empêcher à
tout prix l'adoption d'un d'un texte et
tous les arguments sont sont bons il
compris le RN le RN ne veut pas
l'adoption de ce texte parce qu' il dit
c'est une victoire idéologique pour nous
oui bien sûr je crois surtout qu'ils
essaient de mettre le bazar chez les uns
et les autres nous on reste sur notre
ligne sur une ligne qui est évidemment
amendé des discussions que nous avons pu
avoir avec avec les les LR donc nous on
reste droit sonot après qu' a des
gesticulations des tentatives de de
récupération la part du RN c'est c'est
toute relativement classique est-ce que
vous avez l'impression d'être en train
de beaucoup céder aux républicains de
trop céder aux républicains mais le
compromis par nature oblige les uns et
les autres à bouger par rapport à ces
positions initiales moi ce que je
constate c'est que hier soir avant la
suspension de de de séance nous avons
voté pour le rétablissement de l'aide
médicale d'État
euh la majorité sénatoriale avait voulu
supprimer l'aide médicale d'État pour la
transformer en aide médicale d'urgence
au Sénat et cette aide médicale d'État a
été réétabli hier soir en en CMP donc
c'est des concessions de de part et
d'autre c'est l'esprit même d'une
discussion toute façon c'est bien clair
personne n'est majoritaire à la CMP donc
si nous voulons un texte qui vienne
protéger les Français contre les
délinquants étrangers en facilitant les
reconduites à la frontière si nous
voulons un texte qui vient mieux réguler
les flux migratoires et mieux intégrer
les étrangers qui ont vocation à rester
sur le territoire bien évidemment qu'il
faut un accord avec leslr il n'y a pas
d'autres VO possible on va parler du du
fond du texte et des points bloquants
pendant la suspension vous êtes à la
Matignon voir ellisabeth band que vous a
dit la première ministre mais évidemment
que la première ministre s'implique
fortement dans dans ce texte comme la
comme le fait également Gérald d'Anin
Olivier du sopt donc en tant que chef de
la majorité effectivement elle a
rassemblé à à matigon les membres de la
CMP qui se reconnaisse dans la majorité
présidentielle mais pour vous dire quoi
qu'il faut un accord à tout prix il n'y
a pas d'accord à tout prix ni de la part
ni du côté des LR mais monsieur
retaillot vous le dira mieux que moi ni
du côté de la majorité présidentielle il
y a pas d'accord à tout prix il y a la
volonté je crois partager sincère
d'arriver à à un accord mais après dans
tout discussion parfois il y a des
incompréhensions des points de blocage
qui reste encore à lever et c'est bien
pour ça que nous nous revoyons tout à
l'heure mais est-ce queil y a eu des
nouveaux points de blocage qui se sont
ajoutés hier c'est ça qu'on a un peu du
du mal à comprendre est-ce que c'était
pas acté avant ce qui était bon ce qui
était pas bon et ce qui rest à discuter
à 17h mais rien n'est jamais acté tout
tout n voilà il reste toujours un espace
de de discussion au moment de de de la
CMP effectivement il y a il y a un sujet
sur les APL qui avait pas forcément été
complètement envisagé avant de la
réunion de la CMP mais il y a rien de
dramatique à ça je vous dis ceuxl même
qui nous reproche d'avoir discuté avant
la CMP sont les mêmes qui nous reproche
d'arriver sans avoir un texte qui soit
bouclé donc voilà il y a une discussion
qui se poursuit nous av avons toute la
toute la journée pour y arriver et vous
êtes optimiste sur le fait de trouver un
accord ben je crois qu'il y a une des
bonnes volontés à la fois du côté LR et
de la côté majorité présidentielle moi
je veux pas me résigner effectivement à
ce qu'on laisse notre pays sans texes
sans texte qui permettent de mieux
contrôler les flux migratoires nous
avons une situation qui est difficile
sur la question de la l'immigration non
seulement en France mais dans toute
l'Europe hein depuis 2 3 ans on assiste
à à à un afflux important de personnes
étrangères lié à la situation
internationale liée aux questions
climatiques et donc nous devons adapter
notre droit à ces nouvelles réalités
migratoires et je crois que sur ce
point-là nous sommes très largement
d'accord avec leslr mais au-delà de ça
avec pratiquement je crois 67 % des
Français ouais justement on va parler on
va parler du fond du texte ce que ce sur
quoi vous avez avancé ce qui coince
notre journaliste Alex Poussard nous
[Musique]
rejoint
bonjour Alex bonjour Arian bonjour
Olivier bit bonjour et Alex on l'a dit
la négociation coince notamment sur les
allocations logement pour les étrangers
expliquez-nous pourquoi alors pour bien
comprendre il faut partir d'un
amendement qui a été voté par la
majorité de droite du Sénat en novembre
pour modifier le projet de loi
immigration cet amendement il prévoit
pour les étrangers en situation
régulière de conditionner le versement
de certaines aides sociales à 5 ans de
résidence régul hier en France contre 6
mois actuellement ce durcissement il est
censé selon les auteurs de cet
amendement et bien lutter contre un
appel d'air migratoir et il concerne les
aides sociales dites non contributives
donc il ne repose pas sur des
contributions sociales et les aides
suivantes les allocation familiale la
prestation de compensation du handicap
l'aide personnalisée au logement et le
droit opposable au logement 5 ans de
résidenceces régulières c'est par
exemple ce qui est prévu actuellement
pour qu'un étranger puisse toucher le
RSA ça c'est pour la version du du Sénat
le problème c'est que la majorité
présidentielle est contre ce
durcissement elle l'avait supprimé en
commission des lois à l'Assemblée
nationale et les deux camps depuis
quelques jours ont essayé de trouver un
compromis en assouplissant la version du
Sénat alors dans ce compromis et bien la
prestation de compensation du handicap
serait retiré de ces ans de résidences
minimales régulières une une distinction
pourrait être opérée entre les étrangers
qui travaillent et ceux qui ne
travaillent pas et la question est de
savoir si les allocations logement
devait être soumise à cette obligation
de 5 ans de résidence c'est ce que
souhaitent les républicains mais la
majorité présidentielle estime que non
d'où le blocage et la suspension de Séan
hier à 17h une suspension demandée par
le président du groupe LR au Sénat Bruno
rotaillo qui d'ailleurs à tweeté pour
l'expliquer je le cite contrairement à
ce qui nous avait été dit nous avons
découvert que les APL les aides
personnalisées au logement avaient été
réintégré dans la liste des prestations
que peuvent percevoir les étrangers
avant ces 5 ans de résidence régulière
donc les Appl c'est donc le principal
point de blocage de la négociation et ce
point de blocage il commence à crisper
même au sein de la majorité sénatoriale
du côté des centristes qui forment la
majorité au Sénat avec les LR puisque
les centristes veulent absolument un
accord sur ce projet de loi immigration
écoutz le président du groupe centriste
au Sénat rvé Marseille qui était et bien
à notre micro au téléphone hier soir je
suis pas totalement convaincu que les
Français comprennent qu' en pleine nuit
on s'arrête sur un problème d'APL enfin
je veux dire aussi aussi important soit
le le sujet euh ça fait 1 an un an pile
qu'on discute de tout ça euh si on n'est
pas foutu dans un pays comme la France
de trouver une solution c'est qu'il y a
un problème institutionnel
euh parce que c'est pas laffire des
appels qui peut faire capoter un dossier
comme celui-là Olivier Bitz est-ce que
vous avez vous aussi le sentiment que ce
blocage sur la question des appel c'est
un prétexte et ça va plus loin je crois
que le président Marseille comme souvent
d'ailleurs fait preuve d'une grande
sagesse lorsque il dit qu'effectivement
c'est pas ce sujet APL qui doit bloquer
l'ensemble d'un texte de loi dont nous
avons besoin il faut ramener le débat
que nous avons eu hier soir sur ce qu'il
est exactement par rapport à un projet
de loi qui doit protéger les Français
notamment contre les délinquants
étrangers donc il y a un sujet sur les
APL il doit encore être traité dans
est-ce que vous avez sentiment que c'est
un prétexte et que leslr l'utilise pour
bloquer un peu le processus à ce stade
ce n'est pas ma conviction je crois qu'
qu'il y a une volonté sincère d'avancer
de de part et d'autrre je crois aussi à
un moment donné dans une discussion qui
porte sur des dizaines d'articles il
peut y avoir des éléments
d'incompréhension qu'il faut clarifier
c'est l'objet des discussions qu'il y a
actuellement mais effectivement il faut
pas jeter le bébé avec l' Dubin nous
avons un texte qui est un texte solide
un texte de compromis qui vise
effectivement à doter notre pays d'une
législation conforme aux besoins au
besoins de la France donc nous devons
réussir à à dépasser ensemble cette
difficulté mais qui est une vraie
difficulté mais qui ne concerne qu'un
point qui ne concerne qu'une partie d'un
article surt plus d'une soixantaine
d'articles qui eux ne posent pas de
difficultés entre LR et majorité
présidentielle restons sur ce point sur
ce durcissement des conditions pour
avoir les aides sociales non
contributifes pour les étrangers
durcissement qui est proposé par la
droite sénatoriale quels sont les lignes
rouges pour la majorité présidentielle
dans le compromis à trouver ben vous
comprendrez bien que euh euh dans la
journée nous allons avoir un certain
nombre de débats et c'est pas moi qui
sur un plateau euh de télévision va
indiquer quelles sont les lignes rouges
et les les stratégies de de discussion
euh de la majorité présidentielle ce que
je vous dis simplement c'est que je
crois qu'il y a une volonté de part et
d'autrre d'avancer sur ce sujet et de
permettre l'adoption d'un texte le
président Marseille a raison il faut que
nous réussissions à tout prix euh à
avoir à avoir un projet de loi dont nous
avons besoin et dont les Français
veulent 67 % des Français s'exprime
favorablement sur ce projet de loi donc
il faut entendre ce que disent les
Français nous cette CMP se se fait sous
les yeux se réalise sous les yeux des
Français est-ce qu'on est'est pas avec
cette proposition de la droite
sénatoriale en train d'accroître une
forme de priorité nationale pour les
aides social entre les Français et les
étrangers qui ont des titres de séjour
réguliers c'est un sujet effectivement
mais vous savez dans une discussion
chacun doit faire des compromis hier
soir je je je l'indiquais auparavant
nous avons voté le rétablissement de
l'aide médicale des les LR n'en voulait
pas a priori dans la la lecture àant le
texte adopté par par le Sénat donc
chacun do vous l'avez voté Olivier Bitz
en contrepartie d'une lettre écrite
d'Élisabeth borne à Gérard Larché
garantissant un texte au début de
l'année mais bien sûr parce que l'aide
médical d'État a besoin d'être réformé
c'est bien la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement avant le vote du projet de
loi au Sénat avait demander à monsieurs
stéphanini et Evin la remise d'un
rapport qui visait précisément à adapter
l'aide médicale d'État aux réalités aux
réalités de notre de ce qu'est
aujourd'hui l'aide m de ce que
aujourd'hui l' médical d'État en
direction des étrangers donc oui
effectivement il y a une besoin de
réforme et ça ça a été dit dès le départ
et c'était précisément l'objet de la
demande de rapport à mieurs stéphanini
et Evin juste parce c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup parlé des appel c'est le point
qui coince hier soir combien vous avez
examiné d'articles et où en êtes-vous
sur quoi vous vous êtes mis d'accord
nous avons
d'abord procéder à à ce qu'on appelle la
discussion générale he où chacune des
chacun des rapporteurs et chacune des
formations s'exprime sur le texte et
nous avons abordé article par article
effectivement ce projet de loi et nous
nous sommes arrêtés après une quinzaine
d'article je je crois mais qui traitait
à la fois du titre pour les étrangers
malades à la fois de l'aide médicale
d'État mais aussi du durcissement du
renforcement des conditions pour le
regroupement familial donc il y a eu
dans cette Pr première série d'articles
à la fois des mesures on va dire de de
de de fermeté de de de de meilleure
maîtrise des flux migratoires mais aussi
la prise en compte des situations
humaines car ce sont des situations
humaines que nous avons à gérer lorsque
nous parlons d'un texte sur
l'immigration vous êtes également mis
d'accord sur le rétablissement du délit
de séjour irrégulier oui effectivement
ça fait partie des des articles qui ont
été votés hier soir ça veut dire que
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment le
texte il penche quand même
considérablement à droite ce matin mais
moi je ne sais pas exactement ce que ça
veut dire pencher à gauche ou à droite
moi ce que je constate aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a une difficulté à intégrer les
étrangers qui arrivent sur notre
territoire et que ce texte va nous
permettre par l'affirmation des valeurs
de la République mais aussi par les
exigences concernant la la maîtrise de
la langue française de mieux intégrer
les Français qui qui qui viennent sur
notre sur notre territoire est-ce que
c'est de gauche est-ce que ce de droite
je sais pas exactement
ce qui est certain également c'est que
nous avons une augmentation par exemple
du nombre de demandeurs d'asile nous
étions en 2022 à plus de 130000 demandes
c'està-dire une progression de plus de
27 % d'une année sur l'autre évidemment
il s'agissait pas de remettre en cause
l'asile par ce texte là par contre il
s'agit de tirer les conséquences lorsque
l'asile a été refusé aux personnes qui
l'ont demandé ben de pouvoir reconduire
à la frontière les personnes qui ne sont
pas menacées dans leur pays d'origine et
pour ça il faut avoir une législation
plus efficace est-ce que c'est de gauche
est-ce que c'est de droite moi je crois
surtout que c'est le bon sens à partir
du moment où l'asile n'est pas reconnu
aux personnes étrangères qui en font la
demande il est normal de pouvoir les
reconduire à la frontière vous dites
l'objectif de de ce texte est de mieux
intégrer quand on coupe les aides
sociales aux étrangers pendant les 5
premières années est-ce que ça va les
aider à s'intégrer est-ce que finalement
c'est pas en train de devenir un texte
qui a pour objectif tout simplement et
bien de diminuer les flux migratoires
ben évidemment qu' a cet objectif de
limiter les flux migratoires par rapport
à une augmentation que connaît la France
comme tous les pays européens il y a pas
de spécificité française et la plupart
de nos voisins européens des pays avec
lesquels nous pouvons être comparés la
plupart de ces États européens ont déjà
modifié leur législation donc il s'agit
effectivement de mieux maîtriser les
flux migratoires il s'agit également de
mieux intégrer on intègre comment on
intègre d'abord AC avec des aides au
logement par exemple mais moi je crois
que c'est d'abord par l'adhésion aux
valeurs de la République avec le contrat
d'intégration républicaine on intègre
mieux par la maîtrise de la langue
française et on intègre mieux
effectivement en en permettant aux
étrangers de pouvoir de pouvoir
travailler et s'intégrer par le travail
au moment où nos entreprises rencontent
les plus grandesulté à trouver la manœve
nécessaire mais est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment d'être au main des LR dans
cette commission mixte paritaire
absolument pas absolument pas puisque la
la commission mixte paritaire ça qui qui
est extraordinaire finalement aucune des
parties présentes n'a la Major Maité
donc personne n'est dans la main de
personne il y a la volonté avec l'R
d'avancer d'avancer ensemble je crois
que les LR ont fait un certain nombre de
concessions la majorité présidentielle
l' a fait également voilà donc mais il
s'agit pas on va dire de d'intégrer les
les les discours soit de l' nuube soit
du RN qui pour leurs intérêts politique
propre essa d'instiller des éléments de
langage qui ne correspondent absolument
pas à la réalité en tout cas ce que je
vois et vous reprenez vos travau à 10h30
est-ce que vous pensez que l'accord se
fera dans les délais prévus c'est-à-dire
pour permettre un vote à 14h30 au Sénat
écoutez très franchement j'en sais rien
au moment où nous parlons je ne sais pas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut mais
vous pouvez vous laisser la journée pour
négocier ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut
se donner le temps d'arriver à un accord
s'il y a un blocage que nous n'arrivons
pas à surmonter et ben ce sera très
dommage mais ne nous mettons pas
nous-mêmes une pression exagérée pour
réussir dans un timing trop serré est-ce
que vous êtes inquiet du vote de ce
texte alors pas tant au Sénat mais à
l'Assemblée notamment l'aile gauche de
la majorité est-ce que vous pensez
qu'elle suivra votre accord quel que
quel qu'il soit ce qui est certain c'est
que au Sénat ça devrait bien se passer
s'il y a un accord en seté du côté de
l'assemblée que je connais un petit peu
moins bien je crois que là aussi il y a
quand même une majorité de députés quels
que soient les les les banques qui sont
des députés responsable en tout cas je
j'ose l'espérer et moi je fais confiance
aux députés de la majorité pour se
rendre compte à la fois des enjeux pour
le pays et et et se rendre compte que
notre pays a besoin de ce texte donc moi
je je ne sais pas exactement comment les
choses vont vont se passer mais en tout
cas j'espère que tout se passera au
mieux avec un sens de responsabilités
des un et des autres et vous le dites
les Français sont favorables à ce texte
ils attendent plus de fermeté sur la
question migratoire est-ce que ce qui se
passe ces dernières ces dernières heur
n'est pas en train de produire un effet
désastreux sur l'opinion publique ben
c'est sûr que pour l'opinion publique
c'est un petit peu
difficile de comprendre depuis une
semaine ce qui se passe entre la motion
de rejet à l'Assemblée la semaine
dernière où il y a une coalition nups
Ren LR qui qui a visé non pas à rejeter
le texte mais à rejeter le débat par
Cuxa même qui se plaignigne quand même
régulièrement l'utilisation du 493 qui
priverait l'Assemblée nationale de débat
effectivement il il y a une série
d'éléments qui sont difficilement
compréhensibles par par l'opinion mais
là chacun comprend bien qu'à part par du
moment où on veut arriver à un accord
sur un texte aussi important que ça
mette un petit peu de temps on suivra
évidemment ce qui se passe ce matin
merci Alex à tout à l'heure et oui on
parlera des enjeux de cette journée qui
va être importante pour le projet de loi
immigration évidemment et ce sera à
suivre tout à l'heure dans le club on va
continuer à parler de ce sujet puisque
ça fait aussi la une de la presse
régionale et notamment du côté de Toulon
où on retrouve guilemme ricavi bonjour
guilem merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce matin directeur éditorial à Var Matin
et à la Une justement de votre journal
Guillem témoignage de et de
travailleurs oui effectivement on a
voulu s'intéresser à ces personnes sans
papier ces migrants arrivés en France et
notamment dans le sud-est souvent par
l'Italie et qui travaillent sans papier
certes mais qui remplissent des
fonctions dont leurs employeurs auraiit
du mal à se passer et c'est ces
témoignages effectivement que l'on
raconte dans le journal aujourd'hui dans
Var Matin et d ni ce matin des salariés
donc sans papier mais qui ont besoin de
travailler et de l'autre côté et bien
des employeurs qui explique qu'ils n'ont
pas le choix non plus pour poursuivre
leur activité que d'avoir recours à ses
salariés dans leurs entreprises au
quotidien vous voulez dire un un un
petit mot une petite question à à au
sénateur guilem ou on enchaîne sur la
suite bah oui non moi j'ai une question
effectivement parce que c'est ces cas
très précis ces témoignages qui ont été
raconé dans dans dans notre journal ce
matin pose effectivement la question de
secteur d'activité où en France on peine
à a trouver des des salariés pour les
faire et comment fait-on au-delà de la
question des des migrants dans notre
pays pour ces employeurs qui font face à
à des pénuries de main d'œuvre alors
effectivement c'est d'abord l'article 4
bis hein du projet de de loi pour
rentrer dans la technique qui prévoit
cette possibilité de régularisation pour
les travailleurs étrangers dans les
métiers en tension donc ce dispositif
qui a été négocié entre majorité
sénatoriale et majorité présidentielle
serait maintenu après je je connais un
petit peu le le Var pour y avoir
travailler il y a pas si longtemps que
que ça à Brignol en particulier donc je
je connais la la situation notamment
dans la dans la viticulture et et je
crois qu'effectivement il faut voir
aussi les les résultats de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui a été votée il y
a pas si longtemps que ça et de voir
comment nous arrivons effectivement à
remettre sur le marché du
travail les personnes qui actuellement
n'y sont pas mais qui pourraient
travailler on va parler d'un autre texte
guilem euh Olivier Bitz vous êtes chef
de fil d'un autre texte c'est le texte
qui vise à renforcer la lutte contre les
d dérive sectaire il devrait être
examiné normalement ce soir au Sénat et
guilem dans V matin vous avez fait un un
dossier complet sur ce sujet des dérives
sectaires
oui effectivement il y a quelques
semaines Régine Meier grand reporterur
de Var Matin c'est s'est penché sur la
question parce que on observe de
nouveaux visages de ces dérives
sectaires qui aujourd'hui prennent
racine notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
euh des dérives secteures qui également
s'appuient sur les inquiétudes liées
après la période du covid et également
euh les déserts médicaux puisque de
nombreux territoires aujourd'hui
manquent de médecins et les gens se
tournent assez naturellement à la fois
vers Internet et parfois vers des
médecines parallèles et on voit bien
aujourd'hui que c'est là parfois que
prennent naissance des pratiques et des
dérives c'est en tout cas ce que
l'enquête que VarMatin avait publié à
montré euh à la fois effectivement euh
des sectes 2.0 sur Internet et surtout
des sectes qui s'adressent soit aux plus
jeunes soit aux personnes en situation
de fragilité pour des raisons de santé
notamment guilem une question
oui alors la la question c'est comment
fait-on là aussi aujourd'hui pour faire
face à à cette tentaculaire euh à cette
dérive pardon tentaculaire sur les
réseaux des sectes est-ce qu'on est armé
en France aujourd'hui i pour s'attaquer
à ce qui se passe sur les réseaux
sociaux sur TikTok notamment alors
est-ce que nous sommes suffisamment
armés aujourd'hui en France la réponse
est non d'ailleurs c'est précisément
pour ça qu'un projet de loi sera discuté
ce soir en première lecture au au Sénat
pour justement renforcer on va dire les
les moyens législatifs à notre
disposition vous savez qu'il y a eu les
9 et 10 mars dernier des assises de
lutte contre les les dérives sectaires
et les conclusions de C C assis ça a été
la nécessité d'adapter notre droit et de
créer de nouvelles infractions qui
visent d'une part à prendre plus en
amont les phénomènes sectaires
c'est-à-dire de venir sanctionner la
mise en place d'une person d'une
suggestion à l'égard du d'une personne
et pas seulement d' d'un abus de
faiblesse donc d'intervenir en amont
c'est le premier point et le deuxième
point c'est d'intervenir dans le domaine
de la santé pour faire en sorte que
puisse être sanctionné le fait de
provoquer quelqu'un à ne pas prendre le
traitement dont elle aurait
besoin donc est-ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui l'arsenal législatif adapté
la réponse est évidemment non et c'est
bien pour ça qu'il y a un projet de loi
qui doit être débattu et je l'espère
adopté et qui Deva être examiné ce soir
si tout va bien au Sénat on sait pas
trop du coup ce qui va se passer dans la
journé Guillem on revoit la Une de 20
matin on en a parlé migrants et
travailleurs il témoignent c'est à la
Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
merci guilem d'avoir été avec nous pour
nous parler de ces sujets merci Olivier
bit on vous laisse retourner en
commission mixte paritaire la journée va
être longue pour vous merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous pour nous raconter
ce qui s'est passé ces dernières heures